he's a humble mildly autistic Christmas
tree farm you tree sure are gonna make a
whole lot of families happy this
Christmas
she's the hotshot CEO of a woman's
protein bar company from the big city
you I don't care if it's Christmas you
give me that least my
Friday or you're fired
they were polar opposites until fate
made them collide
all my trees
[Music]
pay for the trees emac down I hereby
sentence you to three days of helping
out on Daniels farm kamee can't we just
pay him for the damages language around
here we give out charming folksy
punishments young lady things started
out frosty Christmas you're not you are
you know nothing like that it's just I
don't
[Music]
but follow along on love is in the air
last year on Christmas Eve my family got
snowed in and I was forced to eat my
husband and two children to survive we
have so much in common my son got into a
sledding accident yesterday and caught
an extremely rare form of rickets he's
dead now I didn't eat him though on
account of the rickets
and that's why I love you no well I love
you too and I've decided not to bulldoze
the town I didn't realize that was on
the table in fact I'm gonna move here to
start a new family with you and open a
coffee slash flower shop slash bookstore
I'm pregnant too by the way
there's a Christmas miracle also I've
actually been an angel this whole time
[Music]
I'm gonna have to raise the baby by
myself me Julia starlet coming this
Sunday to the Hallmark Channel
don't Chris miss it
[Music]